今月は外れの雪をです皆さんデーナシってますでしょうかレンガってこうなんか今を
買おうかなんですけど建物を建てるときレンガを積み重ねて部屋を作ってするんです
けど
家を作るぐらいなんでご存知の通りめちゃくちゃ硬くてやばいんだけどなんかよく殺人
事件とかを連打で頭を叩くっていうのが
バーン
実際聞いたことないですね実際なんですけどそういう中でドラマたがなんかアニメの名
が殺人事件とかでもそういうのあってはっとミニ競技なんですよねになってそんな中
こちらを買ってきました上げていきましょうといないと思うんですよね塩蔵品で頑丈
すぎてやばいこれ
[音楽]
いただけますはぁはぁ
はい今は双撃で20万円のカメラが壊れました
源すずです
だーっ
続きましたはいさーいてくるこちら
ん
例がです頭痛いところなんですけどもう年賀に町議た偽物でございます
ああ
と見わからんなぁ地下で見たらちょっとわかるんですけど拓大版な鳥を撮りましょう
あっパッと見でん金だけで今日はですねやっぱり
ちょっと伸び床をって
いいよねぇラベルですねターゲットが玄関から出た時に上から連が大量に落ちてきたら
どういう反応するのか見てみようと思いますが結果わかっていますビビります縦パスの
で恐怖に怯えた時の声を聞きたいとかそれを糧にドッキリしてみたりとかがあるんで
まぁちょっというグレーで1個暗くなってきたのでなかなかさらにわかりにくいと思う
んですよグサッすぐ仕掛けていきましょう
ん
では行くよ
[音楽]
た
w
ていた
はどんなもんん
なるほどこうせん
はぁ
すー
pr
th
とっ
ん
ポッキーを吐かなかった
ています
astand
同法を見ても蓮宮でしょこよりまカラスたりターゲットがですので
だった訪れめっちゃ降ってくると消していこうと思います
待ってろよたなっちゃ
まず入っ
7加護亜依さん
すごいね
おっ
[音楽]
usa rar
ねえ飯あっはぁっ
me
dea
ええええええ
あっはぁ
car den den den